Washington is gridlocked on important
issues but mayor's across the country
are taking action the mayor of South
Bend Indiana is one of them Peter Pete
Budaj has worked to bring new jobs and
industry to his city he transformed an
old factory into a business park but
tech companies he raised the minimum
wage for city employees and now he is
working on a paid family leave plan the
man is known simply as mayor Pete in
South Bend he's considered a rising star
in the Democratic Party as the United
States Navy reservists he took a leave
of absence in 2014 to serve in
Afghanistan now in his second term
Politico calls mayor Pete Amer to watch
and note speculation about a future run
for governor or even president mayor
Pete Budaj joins us at the table mayor
Pete welcome thank you I guess they call
you mayor Pete cause it's a little hard
to pronounce your last name
that's right luckily elections are
multiple choice though so they don't
have to know how to say it as long as
they can pick it out of the list I want
to talk about you and what you've done
in South Bend but first the news of the
day of course that we know that the
Republican leader in the Senate says
yeah he's just going to put up a vote
for repeal how would that affect a city
like yours well means a lot of people
who live in South Bend including people
I know and care about are going to get
to keep their health coverage at least
for now I think a lot of people are
breathing a sigh of relief you know for
us this isn't about the political points
and who's up and who's down this is
about people who were sincerely and
seriously wondering how they were gonna
get health care if Congress took it away
so this is good news for all of us but
you've already had I mean in your state
alone in Indiana seven insurance
providers have said we're out yeah and
when they do it's largely citing the
instability created by the president
who's talking down a system that a lot
of people depend on could it be better
absolutely but tearing it down or
destabilizing it doesn't benefit anybody
and there are a lot of people whose
family's well-being you know my
partner's mother just to give you an
example she relies on this tuba cream
it's actually chemotherapy for skin
cancer her life depends on this stuff it
would be two three thousand bucks per
month if she didn't have coverage
through the ACA this is about real
people in their daily lives and that's
what the stakes really are for all of us
let's talk about trade and jobs
manufacturing jobs in America have been
going down is there something that can
be done about that and what impact does
trade have on that which seems to be the
mantra of a president Trump well we need
to understand that you can't unglue
belies the world and you can't turn back
the clock on technology what you can do
is create a reality where technology and
trade are a situation where workers have
a place in the economic story other than
that of victim right now in South Bend
we've got workers union auto workers who
are working on a line with a contract
assembly making Mercedes vehicles that
are sold to Chinese customers so we got
American Union Auto Workers making
German cars going to Asian markets
shipping the goods not the jobs to Asia
workers can win in today's economy but
it's not going to happen by turning back
the clock you don't want to start a
trade war but does the president have a
point in which he says there's a lot of
unfair trade agreements in place that
hurt American workers well certainly the
case that American workers feel that
they've been treated unfairly and that's
not just because of trade but are they
right they've been treated unfairly I
think that it's easy to blame trade when
technology has changed a lot of things
but yes workers are being treated
unfairly among other things workers are
being treated unfairly by financial
institutions that are jerking us around
I think the president would rather we
not pay attention to that as he works to
put even less restriction on the way
Wall Street behaves but I think that's
where the action is if you want to make
families better off we come into a point
in which we have to redefine work I
think we might be I mean certainly
technology is changing things profoundly
think about this right now we're
basically at what economists would call
full employment and yet we just had an
election that's a kind of election you'd
have in conditions of intense economic
anxiety how can you have economic
anxiety and most people working at the
same time well means there's more to
jobs than just the unemployment rate or
whether you have one or not let's talk
about you you're 34 years old 35 now 30
35 a degree from Harvard and Oxford you
were a Rhodes Scholar worked as a and
currently a Navy reservist what's in
your a Democrat what's wrong with the
Democratic Party well I think we're
tying ourselves up in knots over what
our message is going to be and sometimes
falling into the trap of the
it's it's all about Russia or it's all
about opposition when the thing that
Democrats in my view have always been
about at least the reason I'm a Democrat
is that we're a party that exists to
defend and support ordinary people going
about their lives I think that's a
powerful message and I think we've got a
lot more going for us as a party than we
think if we give back to our values and
get back to our message so what happened
why did you need to get back your
message and get back and get back to
something what happened to the
Democratic Party so that it lost that so
that in the 2016 election people didn't
think of the Democratic Party that way I
think much focused on identity politics
and it was too much focused on
Washington you know this show has become
so mesmerizing even more so since the
election because it's so twisted we
can't take our eyes off it and so we're
talking about what's going on in the
capital without remembering that the
only reason any of that even matters is
what those decisions do to people in
places like South Beth and Democrats
used to be very good at talking about
that but now we're so consumed with
who's up and who's down and what's
happening in this committee and the
Russia and believe me I get that that
matters but look even if this
investigation leads to a new president
it doesn't change the fact that only
four in ten Americans currently believe
that Democrats are for something they've
got to know what were for not just what
we're against you're a progressive
Democrat in a state that Donald Trump
won by double digits
it's former governors now the country's
vice president what are some ways that
you can work together with Republicans
on because it does seem like that's what
this country is craving well that's one
of the great things about being a mayor
in fact right now I'm here because
Bloomberg philanthropies is convened 40
mayor's from around the world in a
partnership with Harvard to help us all
get better at our jobs and their mayors
I've gotten to know and like to be
honest I'd have to go back and look it
up whether they're Republicans or
Democrats that's not how we think we're
in charge of delivery and I think when
you keep the focus on results when
you're picking up the trash filling in
the holes in the road and working to
create jobs people give you a lot of
credit whether you're from the same
party as they are or not and I'll work
with anybody who can help us do that
because it's not always about ideology
is any reason to believe that an
American with the experience and who
talks about economics and foreign policy
cannot be elected because he or she is
gay
I don't know it's not for me to say but
but what I will say is that when I came
out in a socially conservative community
like South Bend I got reelected with 80%
of the vote I think people don't really
care it's the same as when I was in the
military you know when when I got into a
vehicle that I was responsible for
driving or guarding the people who got
in the vehicle with me they want to know
if I'd read the Intel reports on where
the IEDs might be they want to know if
I'd chambered around in my m4 and if I
knew how to use it they didn't care
whether I was a Democrat or Republican
whether my father did was yeah or
whether I was going home to a boyfriend
or girlfriend
they just cared whether they could trust
me with their lives and I think it's the
same relationship people have to their
mayors and their political leaders well
may I keep her coming thank you so much
for coming by I appreciate it mayor
Budaj